do you remember Alex and Lea hosi yeah
of course Lea was telling me that she
got Alex a gift for Christmas and she
was saying he's such a difficult person
to get a gift for because he could buy
anything he wants so she said it was 5
hours with you and I think she said she
paid like 50,000 an hour he paid 100 125
or something and it wasn't 5 hours it
was maybe 40 minutes 120 grand for 40
minutes he wanted to tap into what I was
doing and understand hey what are you
doing that works and it paid off for him
I mean I think that was 2 years ago
years ago and he's the kind of guy both
of them they'll take something and turn
it into gold and they did we were on
cabon a boat Sabrina and I were on
little skios and we pull up to this boat
and Alex and his wife were on the back
of the boat and they realize it's me in
the water